William Barr now says there is a basis
to indict Donald Trump
but maybe I'll still vote for him in
2024. this is really beyond belief and
it's
it's not beyond belief in the sense that
these Republicans former Trump
Associates and staffers who we say hey
you know what
he or she
they saw the light eventually John
Bolton eventually came out and said
Trump's incompetent and dangerous
whoever the case may be at the end of
the day they are still part of the no
matter how bad Trump is I'm not voting
for a Democrat so let's go through this
this is truly stunning stuff this was an
interview on PBS PBS where Bill Barr was
interviewed by Margaret Hoover and he
believes first and foremost that the
Department of Justice at this point
almost certainly has a legitimate legal
basis for indicting Donald Trump first
clip take a listen in September you said
the justice department was getting close
you said quote getting close to having
enough evidence to indict Trump in the
classified documents investigation but
you also said you hope they don't indict
him
in your view is there ever a
circumstance where you think is
appropriate to indict a former president
oh yes
um
you know if a former president commits a
crime you know especially a serious
crime they should be indicted for it if
the Department of Justice can show that
these were indeed very sensitive
documents which I think they probably
were and also show that the president
consciously was involved in misleading
the department deceiving the government
and playing games after he had received
the subpoena for the documents
that's those are serious that's serious
that's a serious I said I I personally
think that they probably have the basis
for legitimately indicting the president
I don't know I'm speculating but but
given what's gone on I think they
probably have the evidence that would
check the box they have the case
that's pretty clear that's a former
Attorney General saying they probably
have the evidence to legitimately indict
my former boss the former president so
certainly William Barr would not
consider voting in 2024
for a guy who so mismanaged and
mishandled at least some aspects of his
job that his behavior was worthy of an
indictment right I mean William Barr is
a man of the law and of Law and Order
former Attorney General lawyer he would
not say and by the way I'm in a vote to
re-elect that guy who I think we can
legitimately indict
well he might he might vote for him if
Donald Trump were the nominee for the
Republican party again would you support
him
well I'm just hoping it never comes to
that because I think it would be a
tragedy if he's our nominee if he's the
Republican nominee
um could you vote against him could you
vote not for the Republican if Donald
Trump or the Republican again I think it
gets down to what I said which is I
would have to make the Judgment at that
point
the impact on the country and I'll have
to see what's going on in the world what
who the Democratic nominee is if it's a
progressive Democratic nominee I can't
imagine voting but right between a
criminal president
and a progressive I'm not voting for the
progressive I'm clearly voting for the
criminal theologically Progressive
versus somebody who orchestrated an
attack on the capitol whom the trade is
oath to the Constitution as you said in
your words you still might vote for him
yeah yeah I might vote for him sure
betrayed as though sure but at least he
doesn't want Universal Health Care for
everybody I mean that's crazy depending
on all this it's hard for me to project
what the future holds the question is
always a comparative one you have to
make a choice between two people I don't
believe in Throwing Myself Away on a
third party you don't rule out
supporting president Trump again no I
don't
depends on the circumstances what I pray
that that doesn't come yeah
I think the reason our Republic is in
Jeopardy is because we are not throwing
up the best and the brightest for these
offices that's for damn sure that's for
damn sure so a reminder when we stumble
across so-called sensible Republicans
who have figured out the truth about
Trump and blah blah
at the end of the day it's about
self-preservation it's about what's good
for me now I think there are some
exceptions when I look at Mitt Romney
I'm not a fan of Romney but he did have
this brief moment where it seemed like
he was sort of auditioning to be
Secretary of State he went and had
turtle soup and Frog's legs or whatever
it was with Trump uh before Trump was
inaugurated
and it didn't work out that way and
maybe it would have gone differently and
I'd feel differently but Mitt Romney has
pretty consistently stuck to his
framework for conservatism as he sees it
and it has not really overlapped with
trumpism he's been clear he marked
marched with the black lives matter
protesters he has been consistently
anti-trump he entertained it when he met
with Trump that time I it's closer to
a type of Republican I can respect not
in terms of agreeing with their
positions but in terms of how they've
handled all this but the the Bolton the
you know even Liz Cheney to some degree
I I just don't know I just don't know I
think this is basically what we should
expect from all of them and uh Barr says
listen betraying your country and all of
that
better than an ideological Progressive
which tells you a lot of what you need
to know about the Maga crowd if you have
a friend or loved one who is passionate
about the environment here is a perfect
holiday gift our sponsor established
titles is a project that lets you
ceremonially purchase as little as one
square foot of dedicated land in
edelston Scotland so that you can call
yourself a lord or a lady like the
historic Scottish tradition some people
even change their plane tickets or
credit cards to include Lord or lady
your title pack comes with an official
certificate you can see exactly where
your plot of land is located it makes a
perfect last minute gift but most
importantly established titles plants
one free tree for every plot of land
sold established titles does really good
work all over the world with
reforestation organizations like one
tree planted and trees for the future so
you will have a great laugh whether
you're Scottish or not I'm not but
you're giving the gift of reforestation
to fight climate change if you use my
link you'll get 10 off and your plot of
land will be right next to mine you can
see it on a map go to
establishtitles.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman for an extra 10 off on top
of their Black Friday deal the link is
down below